need motivation watch it up 10 the
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something greater
inside you as well you've got Michael
Jordan level talent at something so get
ready to be brave be passionate and
believe with Casey Neistat
in my take on his top ten rules a
success vol 5 to give you the belief
that you need ok let's kick it off with
rule number 1 find your passion
I do a 20-hour day at least five days a
week
if not six days a week and there's
usually a day where I'll sleep sleep in
and get six or seven hours and I have a
three-year-old at home and I think that
especially in the world of YouTube with
sort of the the buzzwords and the
platitudes and the the inspirational
quotes of working hard I'm part of this
I sell a sweatshirt that literally says
work harder on it it's easy to
romanticize hard work but the reality of
hard work is that it's it is what it is
and it sucks and it's nonstop there is
no off switch and and you know I got I
don't need to work hard like we could
leave need expensive New York City and
move somewhere more cost-effective and I
could do nothing but watch TV for the
rest of my life and I can standard age
37 and that's a huge privilege but
instead I work 20 hours a day because I
love every second of it you know when I
was I took a year where I was not
focused on YouTube I focus on a company
and it was a more regular schedule I was
miserable
osmond took away my sense of self was
right so my sense of purpose and that's
why I preface my whole talk by saying if
you find that passion you're
extraordinarily lucky because to do that
digging ditches or washing dishes which
is what I do early in my career it
really sucks but when you love doing it
there's no disassociating your work from
your life your identity from who you are
rule number two believe but I first
moved to New York City I lived in an SRO
like a single room occupancy it was a
place had no bathroom and no kitchen was
a shared
not a great place to live and I used to
ride my bike almost every day like from
where I worked all the way downtown all
the way up to with this huge heavy bag
with like all my camera gear in it and
and this camera gear was like this
burden it was like this weight I knew
that that burden on my back was going to
be what set me free like what all my
dreams could come true if I just
believed in this thing rule number three
know how to brand and market we spoke to
the creator and the the person who's
maybe looking to work on their personal
brand and stuff on the flip side there
are a lot of old-school brands that have
sort of like a dinosaur mentality when
it comes to social media and and
new-school marketing and you being one
of the disruptors in that area
you know you've mentioned you mentioned
Nike known I key and and how you weren't
even wearing anything that was Knightly
what what sort of message you have to
the guys at the top let's say that are
scared to evolve and they're hesitating
because they're used to what works for
them I mean look I think Nike is the
Nike has one of the strongest brands in
the world because they're willing to
take caches on a video like that and the
reason why someone like myself works
well that's a Nike a company like Nike
is because like it's about an ethnos as
much as it's about a product which is to
say that it's very little about the
product um you know I think Apple
computers like their commercials are
never about their products products
they're about an idea and my philosophy
I'm branding and marketing as a whole is
like if you sell the idea people will
invariably buy the product
so all the marketing that I do is always
about ideas it's never about products
rule number four stand out from the
crowd how do you break through on
YouTube or should you bother I mean my
rule is always the same it's like if
you're doing what everybody else is
doing you're doing it wrong if you're
looking to what makes other people
successful and thinking you can emulate
that you will never ever ever find
success in a platform like YouTube
why would somebody possibly take the
Carbon Copy when they can have the
original so I think it requires a truly
inventive kind of thinking
brute force I think that you know if in
the days of television it was one
Episode a week or you know movies a
couple times a year I think on YouTube
like there's such a litany of content
that to really be heard and develop a
relationship with your audience you have
to constantly be putting fresh content
in front of them so I think if you
combine those two ideas like originality
and your creativity and then just total
brute force and hard work that gives you
the best odds and I see those as not
paths to success but prerequisites for
success by doing both of those things
doesn't mean you'll be successful but
without doing them there's no way you'll
be successful also if you want to have
more confidence check out my 254 series
it's free the link to join is in the
description below skill I use probably
communication which i think is building
on what Garrett said I think
communication is - a two-way street rule
number five be unreasonable the
reasonable man adapts himself to the
world the unreasonable one persists in
trying to adapt the world to himself
therefore all progress depends on the
unreasonable man
I am an unreasonable man rule number six
work hard and be brave the generic
advice I always give to young people is
that the two things you need to do to
find success no matter what it is you
want to do is you need to work hard and
be brave if you're willing to work
harder than the next guy and you're
willing to take chances that the next
guy is not willing to take you will find
success rule number seven be realistic
and I'm super cynical and jaded about
YouTube success which is contradictory
to so much of what I share which is that
it is true that it's a fair and open
egalitarian meritocracy it's everybody
has the same entry point the
twelve-year-old kid is here today signs
up for an account the same way that
somebody like me signed up for an
account when I started mine that my own
show on HBO it's the same so the entry
point is the same for everyone but
success is extraordinarily elusive so
when you think of what it might be to be
successful on YouTube and you see the
YouTube stars with their sweet Yeezys
and their Lambos realize that success on
that platform is is less likely than
succeeding as a musician do you want to
be the next Katy Perry because your
chances of succeeding there are the same
as they are or less than or moreso than
they are on YouTube you want to be a
professional athlete it's the same kind
of thing and I think there is this
misconception that because the entry
point is an egalitarian one because it's
a fair one that success is also fair or
more accessible and it's not it's not
there are 1 billion accounts on YouTube
if you're trying to be a YouTube star
there are 1 billion people in some
capacity trying to do that the same so I
I would always caution just how gnarly
of an uphill battle it is it's also
impossible to predict success you can
look at channels that are making
incredible content being at all and say
all I have to do is make incredible
content the ones that throw me off are
the channels that make garbage content
and they're killing it then it's like
what does this person know that I don't
the unwrapping of eggs there's nobody in
this audience I'm a just six really a
plastic tray that gets 500 million years
on those videos my daughter
so no I mean the advice I would have is
don't do it if you can if you accept
that advice then you're making the right
decision if you refuse that advice then
like know that it is a battle like no
other battle and it requires a level of
commitment that then I think most most
people including myself were naive too
until they're in the throes of it rule
number eight say yes to things in 2003
after that video exploded it opened all
kinds of doors for me in places that I
couldn't have really imagined in some
interesting places some weird places
some some some opportunities that didn't
make a lot of sense I I was hired by
like a public-access like a very very
small cable news network to cable
television network to make some local
content for them I didn't know what any
of that meant I just said yes because a
good rule of thumb earlier in your
career is just keep saying yes until
they hand you the check and that's what
I did rule number nine sees
opportunities when I was young my the
dream was always to be a more
traditional filmmaker to make feature
films to work in television to you know
to to to be a part of where I understood
media to be
you know when I was a teenager and then
I just think you know I was very very
lucky to be born at an opportune time so
as technology really shifted and
disrupted what what media is and what
it's come to represent I think all I saw
and that was sort of opportunity to be a
part of whatever's next and you know
after being a traditional filmmaker for
a number of years and working in
television for a couple of years it's
when I really got excited about what
could happen on the Internet and the
power of things like whether it's
YouTube or other social media outlets
when you share video there it's a very
different relationship than when you
watch content and it's in a cinema watch
a movie in a cinema and it got me
excited in a way that I don't think I
could have ever imagined and that's kind
of what pulled me out of the traditional
space in media and really fixed me more
in the the new media landscape and rule
number 10 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is don't let failure
stop you deciding to make that iPod
movie which is really stupid and not a
great movie that was one of these
defining moments and when that guy is
name's Tom Scott he's a brilliant
entrepreneur when he turned to me and
said is there something bigger you
wanted to that was one of those moments
and what we pitched him was this it was
like hey why aren't you his bank roll us
cover all of our expenses for a year and
let us make a bunch of little movies is
not is that not the dream right now
but he seemed a meadow vole I mean this
is a guy who was offering us a huge
opportunity after we had done nothing
but delivered on something that was
nothing like what he hired us for so it
was like maybe I want to take a chance
and he said sure let's do it by the way
him bankrolling us for a year was was
very very little amount of money it was
literally just enough so we would have
to worry about rent we're not talking
about millions of dollars here was
something small and what we did then
what we did then was all we knew how to
do which was make these tiny little
movies and this is 2007 but now in 2018
are described it as essentially YouTube
movies like that's what we were doing
but we didn't know what they were it's
the only thing we knew how to do so he
made these little videos and he would
come once a month and check on us just
to make sure we weren't completely
blowing off this huge deal that we made
with him and he loved the content and
about six months and he walked into our
office with this like very
smart big deal a movie producer and it
was it was like nerve-wracking her name
is Christine vishawn by the way she's a
Oscar award-winning producer she's an
incredible just like brilliant mind in
the world and she watched the content I
remember she like didn't say anything
which is like the worst thing somebody
can do you know somebody's like that
sucks try harder and somebody's like
this is great someone says nothing
nothing is the scariest thing and she
said nothing and then when it was over
she turned and looked at us and she goes
I think that that was very good but wait
let's pray she didn't say I think that
was very good she said I think that that
was very good like she wasn't it was
more like what the hell did I just watch
and she came back to us and she gave us
this piece of advice she was like take
all of those little movies and figure
out how to put them together in a
consumable way like make it so you can
actually watch them and we're like okay
so that's exactly we did we took all
these little pieces of a movie we made
them 20 minutes long we put an intro at
the beginning and we put credits at the
end and then we were like this is now a
TV show do you laugh and so did every
single TV Network we brought it to I
remember one network was like if you
don't find anywhere else to put it we'll
put it on our website and that was like
the most painful thing to hear I was
like defeat but that woman Christine
vishawn she showed it to HBO and I
remember her calling and we were like
hey how'd the meeting go and she said
they liked it and I just remember I was
like she's a restrained one with Astin
means something they liked it
and at the end HBO bought that show for
like a couple million dollars and that
was like the big break that was our big
success don't applaud that was our big
success you guys working on flawed
anyways that was it that was the victory
2008 like climb on top of the
mountaintop like we did it and then
nothing happened like they sat on the
show for two years and when it finally
aired two years later they played it on
a Friday night at midnight can you
imagine what this audience eyes would be
like as my videos were only watchable at
midnight on Friday nights it'd be me and
that guy with that phone that's it
just the two of us and it was it was a
failure like it got cool reviews people
were like this is an interesting concept
no and watch it and that was crushing
that was heartbreaking
and it was in the ashes of that that I
was like you know I'm just gonna do this
on YouTube I'm just gonna do this on
YouTube and I think the ultimate irony
is that if you go back and you watch an
HBO series you'll see it feels and looks
exactly like the content that I now call
a vlog they're content that does two
million views a day every single day
it's the same thing
now I've got a special bonus clip from
Casey on how to build a relationship
with your audience that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
let's go from just watching a video to
taking action here we go question number
one what failure will you not let stop
you number two what's the thing in front
of you that you just need to say yes to
and number three what will you do this
week to stand out from the crowd if
you're gonna take some immediate action
I also want to see you give me a hashtag
believe down in the comments below
I uploaded videos monthly for four years
I had over a hundred million views on my
channel a hundred thousand one hundred
fifty thousand subs or I might even
hundreds of thousands it was a
successful channel by all means but the
first time someone ever asked me for a
selfie was was five days after uploading
the or starting the vlog okay it was
five episodes into that and I can tell
you now eight hundred episodes later
that people on YouTube don't subscribe
to content and I think there's a lot of
truth with a campaign as well miss
people subscribe to individuals and no
matter how good my videos weren't about
how viral they went it was just a video
and until I made the vlog which was
squarely about me people didn't know
what or who they were identifying with
so my biggest learning of the community
are when I first realized what the would
have meant to have a community around
content is that it's about a
relationship that I have that's not true
I don't have that relationship it's a
relationship that nine million people
have with me yeah and and I try my best
to communicate back and make it a
two-way street but it
challenging its its unique and there's
very little precedent for it so it's um
you learn as you go
if you want to see the first top ten
rules I did on Casey check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
I only like the word inspiration I like
the word motivation it's not how you
tell it it's what you tell I always do
my best to operate without fear